Mire,
yo no voy a entrar a valorar las decisiones que hayan
adoptado desde el partido socialista de
de Navarra porque no soy quién para para hacerlo.
Eso tendrá que responderlo nuestros compañeros de
de Navarra. Mire, mi garantía es mi palabra.
Mi garantía es mi palabra.
Y creo que yo, cada vez que haya realizado 1 afirmación,
cada vez que me he comprometido algo,
lo he cumplido
y no pienso dejar de cumplirlo.
Yo puedo entender
que algunos estén intentando
alimentar determinadas especulaciones,
pero yo le digo que a día de hoy,
a día de mañana,
a día de pasado,
a día después de las elecciones autonómicas,
día a día del momento de conformar gobiernos en Euskadi,
el partido socialista de Euskadi,
Euskadi koeskarra,
no VA a firmar 1 acuerdo de gobierno con e.
H. Bildu,
ni VA a hacer lendakari a 1 candidato de h Bildu por